- Some people have been
taking quarantine time
to bake bread and do all
this stuff that I don't do.
(Mayim laughing)
But is it true
that you've been trying out TikTok dances?
And I really wanna see one. (laughs)
- Well, here's the thing.
I think that anyone with
children is probably observing
them playing a lot more video games
than you had planned this summer,
because of the quarantine.
And so one of the things
that I've been trying
to do is find any way
to engage with them, or connect with them,
and yes, my older son
who's 14 has gotten into,
I mean, he's always on his phone,
and usually he's scrolling through TikTok,
which I didn't even know what it was.
So I have a YouTube channel
and so we did a video
that we posted on YouTube
of me, basically, saying to my kid like,
"What is TikTok?
How do I do it?"
There's a lot of this motion.
They've got names for it.
There's a lot of, like no,
and it goes with the song. (laughs)
- Oh my god, I love this!
I think this should be a
challenge for all parents
to have to do.
I tried to do one that Normani,
I can't remember what the,
it was some kind of dance challenge.
There was a basketball involved.
I had to pop it off my behind.
I was like, look--
- They're very fast.
It's like it's very fast,
and I was like, "Why can't we do it slow?"
And Miles, my older son said,
"'Cause you're an old person,
and you shouldn't be on TikTok." (laughs)
- (laughs) 'Cause you
shouldn't be on TikTok,
that's awesome.
So, I ask this only because
you're a neuroscientist
in real life.
How does dancing actually help our brains,
and does it?
- Oh, yes, so, I mean,
any movement is good,
especially for your mood,
especially during quarantine.
That kind of movement, it does,
it stimulates serotonin,
also doing something
that's enjoyable, it increases the amount
of happy hormones that are in your brain
and in your body.
Also, things like
adrenaline are important,
getting your heart moving,
'cause I literally feel
like I've been barefoot
for three months (laughs)
sitting on my couch.
So any time that I'm doing something
other than walking to the fridge,
or the bathroom, it feels
like a real accomplishment,
and that actually is,
it is, it's good for your brain.
It's good for your physiology,
and that's one of, kind
of, the only things,
especially in the heat of the quarantine,
it's really one of the only things
that we have been able to
do, is just move our bodies.
Sometimes it's TikTok dances,
sometimes it's vigorous walking.
- (laughs) Yeah, I'll take walking,
and music, or an audio, or Audible,
whatever, listen to a book.